Leeson California are investigating why
to Sacramento police officers shot an
unarmed black man 20 times and killed
him new video shows the officers opened
fire 22 year old Stephon Clark a father
of two was in his grandparents backyard
when he was killed on Sunday
John Black sermons at police
headquarters in Sacramento where they
have a lot of questions John good
morning good morning well Sacramento
police say the two responding officers
believed Clark was pointing a gun at
them but despite the newly released
police body cam and helicopter video
there are still questions about why
police fired 20 rounds at Clark police
body camera video released by the
Sacramento Police Department shows the
moment two officers opened fire on
Stephon Clark in the video the officers
unload a barrage of gunfire at Clark at
least 20 rounds in all killing the 22
year old police believed Clark smashed a
number of car windows and a sliding
glass door in a South Sacramento
neighborhood Sunday officers chased him
to his grandparents backyard police say
they thought Clark was pointing a gun at
them that's when they fired subjects
down in the backyard
[Applause]
we have security police never found a
firearm only a cellphone we want
everybody see the video and that's why
we made it a priority so that everybody
has the opportunity to see what we have
the opportunity to see they came from
that director came from this direction
the Clark family's attorney Melissa
nulled says nothing in the videos will
justify the shooting you see officer
saying gun gun gun and them opening fire
and for the Clark family they're
promising justice you're gonna know his
name forever John you hear me you're
gonna remember like like how you know
Trayvon Martin the Mike Brown Eric
garner Tamir rice you're gonna know
you're gonna know him you know I'm gonna
remember this Clark had prior run-ins
with the law including for robbery and
domestic violence Sacramento police say
the two officers involved are now on
paid administrative leave
John John thanks